yesterday we told you about Syrian
President Bashar al Assad gassing the
Syrian town of khan shaykhun tuesday
morning using what appears to have been
sarin gas the minimum death toll is now
over 70 it might ultimately be higher
than a hundred including at least a
dozen children over 300 civilians were
injured and again there were no military
combatants in that city the use of
chemical weapons is a war crime Syria
had vowed to stop using sarin gas back
in an agreement from 2013 with the US
and with Russia but Bashar al-assad is a
ruthless dictator he's backed by Russia
continues to kill his own people in
large numbers and we suspect that it was
Assad who carried out this attack on
Tuesday because the Syrian government is
really the only force in Syria capable
of dropping chemical bombs from planes
which is what happened according to
numerous eyewitness and media accounts
now here's the update maybe
unsurprisingly Assad and the Syrian
government are denying that they used
chemical weapons and the cherry on top
is that Russia Assad's ally in the
Syrian civil war is also lying as we now
know saying that what happened was that
an Assad regime airstrike using
conventional weapons hit a rebel
chemical weapons Factory on the ground
and that's where the deadly gas came
from so to say it another way cuz I want
to be super clear about what the at what
the story is Russia is saying Assad was
doing the right thing
going after the rebels who had a bad bad
evil chemical weapons factory which
effectively exploded when the good
Syrian government actors went after it
now the survivors of the attack confirm
actually no the gas was coming from
bombs being dropped by planes which is
once again something that as far as we
know could only have been done by the
Syrian government and there's also
consensus Pat sorry I just hit my mic
there and I hope that wasn't too loud
for the audience there was also
consensus among journalists and and
other governments and human rights
organizations like Amnesty International
that it was the Syrian government that
did
yet again I mean just lives oh it's so
incredibly hard to believe that Isis
given their limited resources now would
be able to not only have chemical
weapons but to have a chemical weapons
Factory it's even harder to believe that
a Syrian Assad air strike would just so
happen to hit that Factory so this is
what totalitarian governments do they
they come up with these insane theories
and just expect their citizens to
believe them and it could could have
been Isis or other it could be another
rebel group as well but the point you're
making is the right one which is we have
no reason to think that they have those
capabilities and we know who does have
the capabilities to relate to use this
type of agent diplomats at the United
Nations are blasting Russia for
defending Assad on this we have a number
of eyewitness accounts about this
there's a thirteen-year-old boy named
Mazzini Yousef a victim of the attack
who said at 6:30 in the morning the
plane struck Iran up on our roof and saw
that the strike was in front of my
grandfather's house I got dizzy and then
fainted in front of my grandfather's
garage I next found myself here in the
hospital the boy's grandmother Ayesha
alt Alawi said she saw blue and yellow
smoke coming from where the plane
dropped the bomb saying quote we started
choking felt dizzy then fainted my
grandson amazeen was trying to wake up
wake up his grandfather three of my
family died and Donald Trump has said
that this has changed his view on Syria
and Assad saying yesterday during a
half-hour press conference that this has
changed his perspective on Assad and
Syria although maybe not surprisingly he
did not have any comment about Russia's
lies about the chemical bombs nor did he
mention Russia at all Russia is a big
big player here and as we know Donald
Trump always reluctant to say anything
negative about Russia not surprising I
guess this time around Pat Trump can't
just flat-out deny that Russia is
telling the truth so instead he's just
not mentioning Russia altogether right
but that's what he can do he could just
not even mention his implicit support of
Assad and that money's the water is
plenty
we're gonna keep covering this and I'm
actually pleased that we're not
getting a ton of email from people
saying that we're just taking the X
approach on this we're sort of looking
at what everybody is saying and trying
to figure out what's true and what isn't
and that's sort of the approach we try
to have with every story and that's my
plan to continue anyway